y
strauss la nueva premier del reino unido
se enfrentó por primera por primera vez
a la oposición del parlamento desde su
llegada al cargo la jefa del gobierno
británico defendió llegar a un acuerdo
negociado para el protocolo de irlanda
del norte y promete entregar su plan
económico este jueves
la unión europea de rusia chocan en
torno al suministro de los hidrocarburos
la presidenta de la comisión úrsula von
der leyen propuso limitar el precio del
gas en ruso para golpear los ingresos de
moscú mientras tanto vladimir putin
amenazó con suspender el suministro de
gas y petróleo si se le imponen dichas
restricciones
brasil conmemora 200 años de su
independencia en una jornada marcada por
la política el presidente ya y
revolucionario se dio un baño de masas
en un acto criticado por sus detractores
por hacer campaña en una festividad
oficial a menos de un mes de las
elecciones los críticos del gobierno
también se tomaron las calles
tiempo de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nuestra señal mi nombre es
juan pupiales la nueva primera ministra
del reino unido- listra se enfrentó este
miércoles su primera sesión de control
en la cámara de los comunes un día
después de haber sido designada como la
nueva jefa del ejecutivo británico tras
defendió ante la oposición sus planes
para encontrar una salida negociada al
conflicto comercial con la unión europea
por el protocolo de irlanda del norte
además informó que el jueves presentará
su plan económico para abordar la crisis
que enfrenta el país ampliamos en el
siguiente informe de samur salgado
su primera cita frente al parlamento
como primera ministra de reino unido
[Aplausos]
[Música]
me siento honrado de ocupar mi lugar
como primera ministra en esta cámara y
asumir la responsabilidad en un momento
vital para nuestro país
atendió las preguntas de los diputados
entre los temas clave que dan luz sobre
lo que será su gobierno está la política
internacional y lo que será su relación
con la unión europea afectadas de la
salida de reino unido del bloque
comunitario
necesitamos resolver el problema del
protocolo de irlanda del norte mi
preferencia es una solución negociada
pero tiene que ofrecer todas las cosas
que establecimos en el protocolo de
irlanda del norte- handbikes golpeó otro
tema vital para los británicos es cómo
enfrentar la crisis energética los
costos de la factura de energía y el
alto costo de vida medios locales
señalan que trozos estaría considerando
un paquete de 115 mil millones de
dólares para ayudar con el aumento del
costo de vida incluido el apoyo para
pagar las facturas de energía
wow tomaré medidas inmediatas para
ayudar a las personas con el costo de
sus facturas de energía y haré un
anuncio a esta cámara sobre este tema
mañana de house o más
pero el líder opositor del partido
laborista keith stammer criticó a la
nueva premier
bueno espero con ansias la declaración
de mañana pero el dinero tiene que venir
de alguna parte y ella sabe que cada
libra de exceso de ganancias que decide
no gravar es una libra extra de
préstamos que los trabajadores se verán
obligados a devolver paypal
a pocos meses de la llegada del invierno
reino unido tendrá que afrontar desafíos
gigantes en temas sociales y económicos
al mando de quien la prensa ya considera
como la nueva dama de hierro
precisamente el suministro de
hidrocarburos sigue tensando la cuerda
entre rusia y la unión europea el
presidente vladimir putin advirtió que
ese occidente le pone límites a los
precios del petróleo del gas su país
suspendería esas exportaciones así lo
afirmó durante el foro económico
oriental que se realiza en vladivostok
putin agregó además que occidente tiene
una fiebre de sanciones para intentar
controlar todo a su antojo pero que esto
no iba a lograr aislar a rusia y que en
cambio estas medidas asegura el amenazan
a todo el mundo un informe y alva
santana
entre aplausos el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin inauguró el foro
económico oriental celebrado en el
puerto ruso de vladivostok con un
discurso marcadamente nacionalista en
medio de la creciente presión de
occidente que enfrenta a rusia desde el
inicio de la invasión australia walk
away y hackers aunque algunos quieren
aislar a rusia como siempre hemos dicho
es imposible sólo hay que mirar el mapa
de tanguarín nievas murnau uno de los
principales puntos del foro la energía
tras el corte de suministro de gas del
nord stream 1 el 31 de agosto por
supuesto mantenimiento la unión europea
ha sostenido que rusia utiliza la
energía como arma y chantaje algo que el
dirigente ruso ha negado aunque ha
advertido que si se llegara a imponer un
límite sobre el precio del gas rusia
detendrá el suministro
además están las obligaciones
contractuales un contrato de suministro
alguien va a tomar algún tipo de
decisiones políticas que vayan en contra
de los contratos simplemente no
cumpliremos con los contratos no
suministraremos nada si va en contra de
nuestros intereses económicos en este
caso no suministraremos gas petróleo
carbón o combustible para calefacción
nada
admite que ton austria ante los
crecientes temores por la tensión en la
central nuclear de zamorilla rusia culpó
a ucrania de crear amenazas para la
seguridad nuclear con sus ataques ya que
supuestamente moscú no ha desplegado
armamento en la central y he visto que
el informe del oiea dice que hay que
retirar el equipo militar de la zona de
la central pero no hay equipo militar en
la estación y otro en electric y lejos
de mostrar arrepentimiento útil a
mantiene que la guerra en ucrania ha
beneficiado a rusia ya su soberanía para
poder desarrollarse y hacer frente al
orden occidental en el mundo
y horas después de estas declaraciones
del presidente putin la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
propuso a los 27 estados miembros
aplicar límites al precio del gas ruso
esta idea que ya había sido planteada
por donde rellena alemania la semana
pasada busca golpear así la economía del
kremlin escuchemos a la presidenta
nuestro objetivo es reducir los costos
del gas y por lo tanto propondremos un
precio tope para el gas ruso con ráfagas
así que aquí el objetivo es que debemos
recortar los ingresos de rusia que putin
utiliza para financiar su atroz guerra
en ucrania mientras tanto los países
bálticos letonia estonia y lituania
llegaron a un acuerdo que restringiera
la entrada de ciudadanos son rusos que
viajen a sus territorios desde rusia o
belarús aunque la política todavía debe
ser aprobada por los gobiernos
nacionales de estos tres territorios se
espera que sea implementada a mediados
de este mes de septiembre juan polo
lucumí nos cuenta más
estonia letonia y lituania acordaron
restringir la entrada a su territorio de
ciudadanos rusos que viajan desde
belarús y rusia esta sería la primera
medida de su tipo en el bloque de los 27
la política general es así los titulares
de visa schengen con una serie de
excepciones me refiero a los ciudadanos
rusos no podrán cruzar la frontera pero
las excepciones por supuesto cubrirán
motivos humanitarios cubrir a los
conductores de camiones motivos
familiares diplomáticos pero se
publicarán respectivamente tan pronto
como los gobiernos lo decidan y habrá
suficiente tiempo de advertencia también
se espera que la prohibición de entrada
esté vigente a mediados de septiembre
luego de que los gobiernos nacionales de
los tres países bálticos la aprueben
formalmente
finlandia que también limita con rusia
no se unirá a esta iniciativa por
motivos legales ya que dicen no saber
aún si es posible aplicar esta medida
para los ciudadanos rusos con visa
schengen emitidas por otros países
europeos
esto se está convirtiendo también en un
tema de seguridad pública este es
también un tema de naturaleza moral y
política y creo que en este punto los
estados bálticos han llegado al acuerdo
y estamos ultimando detalles sobre la
política de restricción después
estricto
en una medida para aumentar la presión
sobre el presidente ruso vladimir putin
el 6 de septiembre la unión europea ya
había avanzado en la suspensión del
acuerdo de facilitación de visas para
rusia de 2017 y suspendió el
reconocimiento de los pasaportes rusos
emitidos en partes ocupadas de ucrania
en los últimos días mientras los ojos
del mundo están puestos en la central
nuclear de sap orilla en ucrania los
combates continúan en la región de
jarque mientras tanto rusia dice que sus
tropas han tomado el control del
asentamiento de codema en la región de
donges veamos el informe
columnas de humo salen de este edificio
después de ser alcanzado por un misil
como supuesto objetivo de rusia según
las autoridades ucranianas
un misil enemigo alcanzó un edificio
residencial en el centro de jarquín como
el edificio es residencial no podemos
descartar la posibilidad de que haya
otras personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros
esta mujer vive dentro del edificio
donde casi queda atrapada
la explosión y la sacudida del edificio
fueron fuertes queríamos salir pero
nuestra puerta se atascó sólo quedaba un
hueco pequeño queríamos abrirla pero la
puerta del vecino estaba arrancada y
bloqueaba nuestra puerta ya no pudimos
salir más mientras tanto se han
reanudado los bombardeos cerca de la
central nuclear de zamorilla un día
después de que el organismo
internacional de la energía atómica
pidiera a ambas partes que delimitarán
una zona segura para evitar una
catástrofe en respuesta las autoridades
ucranianas dicen estar considerando
cerrar la planta por completo englobe
ians en el este del donbass también
continúan los combates y los
los misiles impactan en las casas y los
residentes están cada vez más cansados
hubo una guerra en 2014 y ahora hay una
guerra de nuevo
ucraniano retrocede sus líderes dicen
que la contraofensiva que iniciaron en
agosto sigue en marcha el objetivo es
retomar las zonas controladas por rusia
incluyendo las zonas como crimea que se
anexionaron hace ocho años en noticias
de américa latina' a brasil celebra este
miércoles 200 años de independencia de
portugal más allá de las celebraciones
la jornada ha tenido un fuerte tinte
político y es que a menos de un mes de
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales el mandatario yair
bolsonaro se dio un baño de masas y
también hubo marchas de sus detractores
miles salieron por las calles de río de
janeiro y sao paulo en rechazo al
ejecutivo lo hicieron al ritmo del grito
de los excluidos un movimiento que ya
desde hace 28 años se ha vuelto un
contrapeso frente a las festividades
oficiales mientras tanto en brasilia el
presidente evolucionar o cargó contra
las encuestas frente a una multitud en
medio celebraciones por la independencia
en ciudades como río de janeiro hubo
también enormes movilizaciones en favor
del presidente criticado por hacer
campaña en estos actos de hoy
bolsonaro se encuentra a 10 puntos por
debajo del candidato y ex presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva de acuerdo con
un sondeo publicado este miércoles
bolsonaro ironizó sobre estas encuestas
con un juego de palabras frente a la
consultora datafolha
aquí
note
aquí no tenemos mentiras de data folk ya
aquí está nuestro data pueblo aquí está
la verdad
aquí aquí está la voluntad de un pueblo
honesto libre y trabajador
libre y trabajador
dentro de los documentos que tenía en su
casa en florida el ex presidente de eeuu
donald trump habría uno que describe las
defensas militares y nucleares de un
gobierno extranjero así lo reveló el
diario the washington post según este
medio trama tendrían su vivienda
vacacional de mar a lago archivos a los
que sólo el mandatario y altos
funcionarios de la administración pueden
tener acceso más en el siguiente informe
es un descubrimiento que hace temblar a
los gobiernos de todo el mundo el mes
pasado periodistas obtuvieron pruebas de
que se encontraron documentos
clasificados de alto secreto algunos de
ellos relacionados con naciones
extranjeras en la residencia de donald
trump en florida ahora hay más según el
washington post los agentes del fbi que
registraron mar al lago encontraron un
documento que escribía la defensa
militar de un gobierno extranjero
incluyendo su capacidad nuclear el país
no fue nombrado pero el descubrimiento
supera ya las preocupaciones entre los
funcionarios de inteligencia sobre el
material clasificado que fue llevado a
la residencia privada
otros documentos recuperados describen
operaciones estadounidenses tan secretas
que muchos funcionarios de seguridad
nacional no las conocen estos documentos
altamente clasificados se guardan
siempre bajo llave casi siempre en una
instalación de información segura y con
un oficial de control designado pero
estos documentos se guardaron en mar a
lago con un nivel de seguridad
durante 18 meses después de que trump
dejara la casa blanca los investigadores
creen que había más de 300 documentos
clasificados en la propiedad el
expresidente ha negado haber actuado mal
el pasado fin de semana hizo su primera
aparición pública desde la redada del
fbi en su casa de florida calificándola
de parodia
la vergonzosa redada y allanamiento de
mi casa mar al lago fue una parodia de
la justicia que se burló de las leyes
tradiciones y principios de eeuu ante el
mundo entero el mundo entero estaba
mirando y está conmocionado orden ayer
world in world watch en under sad el
lunes un juez federal concedió la
solicitud de trump de un experto
especial que se encargará de revisar los
documentos incautados en el mar al hago
la decisión probablemente retrasará la
investigación del departamento de
justicia sobre los documentos
con esta noticia de eeuu terminamos esta
emisión informativa pero que desde
nuestra pantalla hay actualizaciones
constantes de información aquí en france
24 y también en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]